- [Voiceover] In any discussion of biology
or discussion of evolution,
the idea of a species will
come up over and over again.
And we have a whole
separate video on species.
But the general idea,
or the mainstream definition of a species
is a group of organisms
that can interbreed,
interbreed, and produce fertile offspring,
fertile, fertile offspring.
So for example, in this
picture right over here,
you have a bunch of species
of both modern elephants and previous,
or now nonexistent species,
that are related to modern elephants.
But today on earth you
have Asian elephants
and you have African elephants,
and they are each a species.
An Asian elephant can interbreed
and produce fertile offspring
with another Asian elephant,
and an African elephant can interbreed
and produce fertile offspring
with another African elephant,
but they can't do it with each other.
An Asian elephant and an African elephant
cannot get together and interbreed
to produce fertile offspring.
We know, people have actually tried this.
But the next question, or
the most obvious question,
and this is one of the central
questions of evolution,
is, well, how do you get these species?
We see drawings like we have on the right,
on the left here we have actually
some of Darwin's original drawings
showing this evolutionary tree,
showing how over and over again
we have this branching from
a parent species into two,
I guess you could say
different child species.
You see this here with the elephants.
At some point, the Asian
elephant and the African elephant
shared a common ancestor,
and it was also, based on this diagram,
a common ancestor
of the mammoth.
And you go even further back,
it's the common ancestor of this species
that I'm not familiar with, the Anancus.
And you can keep going back.
But how does this tree branch?
How do you actually get speciation?
How does the variation
within a population,
within a species get so extreme
and in some ways so
separate from each other
that they can no longer interbreed
and produce fertile offspring?
Well, there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
The most obvious way that you
could imagine this happens,
or maybe the most intuitive way
that you could imagine this happening,
is through geographic separation.
And the technical term for speciation,
which is the formation of new species,
so speciation, actually, let
me just write it this way,
the technical term for speciation
due to geographic
separation is allopatric.
Allopatric speciation.
So speciation is just how,
the formation of new species.
And "allo" comes from the word "other,"
and "patric" comes from the
root or the word "homeland."
So it's really talking
about other geographies,
or other homelands, or
geographic separation.
And one commonly cited example here
are the antelope squirrels.
So if you go to the,
if you were to go to
the American Southwest
a long time ago, before the
Grand Canyon was a canyon,
when the Colorado River was
just kinda going through
and wasn't a major barrier,
there was a parent species,
an ancestral species to
both of these characters
that lived on both sides of the river.
And on different times of the year,
it was able to get across the river,
it's able to, the squirrels on the north
and the squirrels on the south
were able to interbreed and
produce fertile offspring,
so they were all one species.
But over time, the Colorado River
started to erode more
and more soil and rock,
and so this became what we now consider
to be the Grand Canyon.
And so over time,
this became a very significant
geographic barrier.
No longer could, before
they could travel across,
but once it became the Grand Canyon,
it became very difficult or impossible
for them to travel across.
And so now you have these
two different populations.
They have the same parent species,
but they're now geographically isolated.
And since the creation of the,
or while we have the
creation of the Grand Canyon,
since it became very hard
or impossible them to cross,
you've now had enough, both genetic drift,
also natural selection,
these are the evolutionary processes
that we've talked about,
where the Harris' antelope squirrel,
which lives on the south side
and is right over here, it's this picture,
and the white-tailed antelope squirrel,
which lives on the north side.
Even though they look quite similar,
as you can see from these pictures,
they have now diverged enough
that they are different species,
that they no longer will
be able to interbreed
and produce fertile offspring.
So it's fairly intuitive
how allopatric speciation can work.
Geographic separation,
no longer can interbreed,
and over time their genes change
through natural selection
and genetic drift.
But what about situations where
they stay in the same place,
where theoretically,
they could get together,
they could interact.
Could you still have speciation?
And the answer is yes.
And that form of speciation,
where you are still in the same geography,
that is called sympatric speciation.
Let me write that down.
Sympatric speciation.
Speciation.
And examples of sympatric speciation
are a little bit less obvious,
or a little bit less intuitive,
but there's an example that people believe
is sympatric speciation
happening before our eyes.
So this species, the technical
term Rhagoletis pomonella,
I know I'm mispronouncing
it right over here,
this is native to North America,
and before European settlers
brought apples to North America,
they hung out and they laid their eggs
and their maggots were inside of,
or they leveraged the hawthorn
fruit right over here.
So they would go to the hawthorn trees,
and they would lay inside of the haw,
they would use the hawthorn fruit
for their, to lay their eggs,
and for their young to kind of consume.
But once the European settlers came
and introduced apples into North America,
a certain, I guess you
could say a subgroup,
of Rhagoletis pomonella
started to leverage the apples,
so started to lay their eggs
and their eggs and
their maggots would grow
inside of the apples.
And they've actually now diverged,
not into fully different species now.
In theory, they can still interbreed
and produce fertile offspring.
But they don't tend to do it any more.
That it tends to be,
even though they're in the same geography,
and it's not hard to fly
from the hawthorn tree
to the apple tree,
they don't tend to do it.
And because of this behavioral divergence,
that some decide to go to the apple,
some decide to stay at the hawthorn,
they actually are now
developing different traits
that are selected for depending on that,
I guess you could say initial preference,
or that initial bias for
which fruit they want to use
to lay their eggs in.
So for example, the ones
that are in the apple tree,
they now have, their breeding cycle
is more aligned with the
growing season for apples,
while the ones in the hawthorn tree,
their breeding cycle is
more aligned with what,
for the growing cycle for the hawthorn.
And so biologists believe
that this is an example
of sympatric speciation
happening before our eyes,
that if we were to wait
a few hundred more years,
possibly a thousand years or more,
that this will diverge
into two different species
that will no longer be able
to interbreed and produce
fertile offspring.
Another example of sympatric speciation,
which is a little bit
more wild in some ways,
it's a little bit more out there,
but this would be an example with plants.
So as we learn in other
Khan Academy videos,
organisms like human beings,
and in fact many sexually
reproducing organisms,
they're diploid organisms.
They have two sets of chromosomes.
For example, human beings have
two sets of 23 chromosomes,
for a total of 46 chromosomes,
23 from your mom, 23 from your dad.
And so we are diploid organisms.
And in general, there are errors
that occur during reproduction
and errors that occur during meiosis
that can lead to polyploidy,
where an organism can have
more than two sets of,
or can start, or a potential organism
could have more than
two sets of chromosomes.
In the animal kingdom,
that doesn't work out too well.
Usually, that does not
produce a viable embryo,
a viable zygote.
But in the plant kingdom,
this is, it tolerates
it a little bit more.
So you could have a situation
where you have a diploid plant,
and through meiosis,
through an error in meiosis,
instead of producing
haploid egg and sperms,
it produces diploid egg and sperm,
which then are able to get together
to form a tetraploid plant,
so a plant that has
four sets of chromosomes
instead of two sets of chromosomes.
And then once that
tetraploid plant exists,
it might only be able to reproduce
with other tetraploid plants
versus the diploid plant.
So you have the diploid plants here,
when meiosis is working "properly,"
and I'll put that in quotes,
'cause maybe, you know,
arguably this error
is what helps for a speciation sometimes,
especially in the plant kingdom,
it is, it can produce
this haploid egg or sperm.
The tetroid plant would then,
would, through its meiosis,
its ploidy, I guess you could say halves,
when it goes to the egg or the sperm,
but you're now going to have a nonviable
or infertile triploid plant,
because the separation
won't happen properly
in meiosis for this egg,
if it's even viable.
So all of a sudden this tetraploid plant
is now a, you've had speciation occur.
It could be viewed as a new species.
And you could think about
things like this happening
as a potential, and we
don't understand all of it,
we don't understand how
all of the speciation
that we now observe has actually occurred,
but you can even imagine
as this being a mechanism
for why you have an increase
in the number of chromosomes
in certain species versus others.
So hopefully this is starting
to answer some questions,
and hopefully even
introduce more questions,
'cause this is a very exciting topic,
about how we get species from,
more species, how do we get the diversity
from parent species or ancestral species.